very sad story out of Paris today sure
you all heard about this Tara just
really painful to watch a massive fire
at the iconic 13th century cathedral
Notre Dame and we're all hoping of
course that they're saying that I don't
think anyone was hurt and they're saying
that they think maybe they can one day
rebuild yeah the main structures main
structures yeah okay and that's but just
just colossal damage and a lot of people
talking about it and of course you know
if people were talking about something
you know what that means
president Trump just had to tweet about
it he had to tweet about it this was his
real tweet from earlier today check it
out so horrible to watch the massive
fire at notre-dame Cathedral in Paris
perhaps flying water tankers could be
used to put it out must act quickly
let's roar very grateful to the
president for suggesting that in the
case of fire water and acting quickly
might be a good idea but his heart was
in the right place and the thing is it
would have been okay if he's if that had
been it but he didn't stop there he kept
tweeting out suggestions to the French
government throughout the entire day
there's this one dear Paris they have
these at Costco maybe use them on the
fire then there's this one heart is
breaking for Paris one of the nicest
cities in Spain and finally he just got
off the phone with the coach of Notre
Dame who told me the basketball team was
unaffected
hashtag go Fighting Irish